my go-to McDonald order is two
cheeseburgers nuggets in front of the
dollar ones yeah and then I'll stuff the
nuggets and the fries oh you can't do
the ritual and then afterwards I nap
McDonald's is great because it's the
same everywhere you go yeah I don't go
to fast food places often but I'll
usually go to McDonald's I love
McDonald's and it's always my go-to
fast-food for when I'm feeling like I
want a treat I go to McDonald's enough
I'm paying at least one person salary I
feel like I never really eat it because
I always feel like there isn't healthy
options but hopefully there's gonna be
different options because it's
McDonald's yeah I trust him it actually
feels like a burger should feel you know
nice and greasy and that's the sign of a
good burger in my opinion right mine
looks like somebody like cut off a third
of it to make the sandwich even
healthier
[Music]
egg whites and light oh wow a
seven-course anneal thing yeah you have
a lot of food but mine feels like it's
more like gonna fill me up more not
gonna lie it's it's dripping already can
you see that I can drink this afterwards
I can't believe this is low calorie
because it still looks like it's like
bad for you it's not as bad as I
expected a little worse let's do it okay
it's not bad at all and even their fruit
isn't bad and I definitely thought the
fruit was gonna be mushy oh yeah this is
legit oh really
mm-hmm I will probably stick with a
burger if I ordered this I'd order with
fries maybe all right I went to
Hartley's she's just over a regular
McMuffin cuz offers a too greasy this
tastes a little too good and it makes me
think that they took like the fat from
the french fries I'm moving I don't like
oatmeal as much it looks like a little
small side salad that you'd get at a
restaurant it's pretty solid eat all
right I also have a parfait how is that
healthy that's just full of sugar this
is a little weird this is the carrot it
looks like they like took a carrot and
then unrolled it yeah yeah no it's good
too yeah yeah that's the girl I'm like
pleasantly surprised it seems fresh yeah
I'm pleasantly surprised I would
definitely order this to the side so it
is low-calorie but it's definitely a
little bit more sugar than what I would
want in the morning time I've never
really like ordered a salad from a fast
food place but if they're like this I'd
get this I didn't know who does have
anything like this like I knew they had
like oatmeal and stuff like that but
this is like a real surprise to me
Starbucks has like an egg white thing
that I always knew was healthy but I
didn't think that anybody else really
had it fast foods always go to and cheap
and it's easy and it's really nice to
know that there's a healthy choice I'm
like glad that they have things that are
a vegetarian and be like different
options as opposed to getting a sandwich
it's good to have these options
available instead of like french fries
[Music]